this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised is why the inclement ride is
such a firm favorite
Kito it looks ready for a fight this is
still insane
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
another installment of Safari lives it
promises to be another epic epic week
we've just had a big storm out here in
juma in South Africa and well hopefully
that's going to mean our cats are going
to be out and about trying to kind of
mark territory and looking for all kinds
of things as they kind of walk around in
the coolness of the afternoon my name is
Tristan on camera I've got Sebastian
this afternoon and we are coming to you
from not only South Africa but Kenya and
we encourage all of you to ask many many
questions remember that Safari lives is
a celebration and a catch up of all of
our characters that we've seen over the
past week and that means we want to hear
about all of your kind of questions that
you have about our characters remember
to try and keep it relevant to those
that we are seeing and hopefully we'll
be able to answer as many questions as
possible and you can send your questions
to hashtag Safari live or @fc on YouTube
and we'll try like I says to get through
a lot during the course of this
afternoon it promises to be a really
epic epic day now that we've had some
rain I'm hoping things are going to come
alive now I was saying we are going to
be focusing on our cat characters it's
been another absolute bumper week and
well take a look at where our cats have
been moving
the first rains of summer might have
arrived at Juma this week but they sure
didn't put a dampener on the characters
making regular appearances as usual the
little chief wasana
started the week in the center of Juma
he then moved south before hitting
northeast scent marking as he went
meanwhile ting gana made his way south
deep into Juma with an unknown Shia
female in tow after a couple of days of
mating they then returned back to the
north Tandi until amber made a welcome
albeit brief appearance in the southeast
and continued to hit north ease back
into tortured being Coomer pride also
arrived at Gallagher pan this time on
the trail of a herd of buffalo as dark
as fell they followed the Buffalo
further south we finally got another
glimpse of the Juma clans newest
additions this time at the Aubrey's Road
din up in the north the Mara was busy as
the paradise pride were once again found
close to the river the olive oil pride
meanwhile moved further south down the
escarpment following the large herds of
wildebeest the Sierra surprised us down
Cooney Beach to round out a still a week
with our cat characters well as you can
see it was a really busy week not only
here on Juma but up in the Maasai Mara
with many of our characters making
appearances and it's shaping up to be a
really kind of interesting yeah as we've
kind of moved from you know hasana being
the young male around who's starting to
show signs of kind of being well to sort
of progressed into dominance so it'll be
interesting to kind of see how
everything plays out but while we
explore and see if we can help find
wasana this afternoon let's try and send
you back up to Steve who well should be
out in the grassy plains of East Africa
hopefully looking for the prowling cats
that are often evil the beasts herds
to the Mara triangle we are up here on
the base of the all along escarpment
with a very nice herd of wildebeest one
or two zebra in tow my name is Steve I'm
joined on camera by Archie and it is a
very nice well apparently 21 degrees
Celsius 75 degrees Fahrenheit although
the weather's pulled in and is windy and
it's pretty miserable but we have been
with a pride of lions for the last few
hours and they were hunting this herd of
all the beasts by me and now we've lost
them somewhere there in the rocks we've
given them a lot of space we moved
around and we're trying to see if
they're going to come out but could it
be awesome it was a nice pride of a 5-1
young male to young females and to
adults and we spent some time with one
of the younger females actually pulling
off what was actually not a bad sort of
stalk so you're pretty close and right
at the last minute she blended it by
running a little bit so blatantly
towards a herd of wildebeest that then
well just all moved away and they all
looking very relaxed considering there's
a hungry pride of lions somewhere in the
grass here busy lurking around doing
whatever it is that they're doing they
might have even gone back to their
slumbers because we found them this
afternoon due to some vulture activity
we found the remains of a wildebeest
from either this morning or last night
so they are not actually that hungry but
they have been interested nonetheless
with the abundance of general game out
here on the open plains and when the
wind is blowing it is always a nice time
for Lions to hunt so a gentleman that
spend a lot of time up here in the Mara
he's now down in Juma Brent Leo Smith
welcome welcome to the greater Kruger
National Park I thought I spotted
something I am looking for hasana
a little chief my name is Brent Claire
Smith I had to have dangerous Dave East
all the objectified dish on camera with
me today so we are searching for a sauna
he was seen in the middle of the day
around the main access road into
Jumma and we think he might have moved a
little bit further to the south now of
course we've had quite a bit of rain
throughout the day which has obliterated
his tracks but Rex and Trista giving me
a hand hopefully we will be able to find
him remember hashtag Safari live if you
want to get your questions through to us
Lulu is wandering to the storm bring
that much water
Oh Davi roll is fighting and of course
now they stop I was hoping they might do
their characteristic roll let's have a
look he might roll and he flies no he's
building a bit of height and we're gonna
do a roll there we go
no roll just the landing oh yeah all
right sorry I got sidetracked by the
lila crested rollers um it didn't
actually bring much water at all so just
enough to sort of dampen the ground and
and and white clear the tracks so if we
do find any tracks on top of the rain
there are going to be very fresh because
it only stopped is this the smelly wall
jog that Jamie had the other day I think
it is nice set of deep on this guy now
if I remember correctly this warthog was
munched on by the mcgann boys those
unfortunate the mangy boys okay well
speaking of Jamie let's go see which of
our favorite cat characters she's off to
find
I was planning on finding the in comas a
very good afternoon to all of you and
welcome to this episode of safari lives
my name is Jamie and I'm searching for
the in Kakuma pride of lions who were
right here when I left them this morning
now as has told you we had a massive
storm by you know dry season standards
we had a massive storm a few minutes ago
and I think it's caused them to wander
off and go off in search of shelter so
this morning we had 18 kuma lionesses as
well as one mangani male and although
this poor young male kept trying to edge
closer and closer to a pride he's not
part of it and the lionesses were not
friendly they were growling at it they
didn't really allow him to approach
wonder but this feeling that they hadn't
gone far into the bush I really feel as
though they might be around here
somewhere but I don't know where cats
are cats they don't necessarily enjoy
the rain all that much and they will
seek out shelter underneath the bushes
I'm going to have a chat to some of the
other guides see if maybe they can give
me some input as to where they might
have moved off to let's go - Brent whose
cat has also wandered off into the wild
still haven't managed to find that a
little chief but there we go let's look
let's go try run over Tristan so let's
see maybe they've got an update for me
maybe they find some found some tracks
and that's why they're heading in this
direction I didn't see any tracks up on
Zoe's road so I'm just gonna go have a
quick chat - Tristan while I do that
we've had some wonderful moments with
our little chief behaving quite
interesting me earlier this week
Kasana has been displaying some worrying
tendencies it shows he is growing up he
is starting to scent mark vigorously the
question is how long wilt in Ghana
tolerates this insolent behavior as
always a member of the ever-present Juma
can paid the little chief a visit in
hope that husana might have a free snack
asana stood his ground and with no food
around the Heine moved off under the
watchful eye maybe get a little chief
with one of the Juma clan having a pesky
look now Tristan and and Rix have not
found any any tracks after the rain yet
so are we gonna take a bit of a gamble a
facade normally comes this way tends to
like to head towards tree house down so
we're gonna go check Fulham on step down
towards trail stand forget nothing there
we're gonna work our way back to the
northwest
oh I'm just this thing next to you
I to the north sounds acting Ghana is
still busy with his lady friend but in
the north in Buffalo cat that so very
wet pregnant Impala disappearing have
you seen his on Impala no you're not
talking to me fine be like that Sandra
is wondering what's happened to tumba I
think the last I heard he was seen to
the south west on LAN deluzy and is the
last I heard of tumba Tristan might
actually have a better idea as he he's I
haven't been in the sands for quite some
time and me hmm actually I haven't seen
Tambor in a long time I haven't even
heard of tumblr but I lost I heard he
was down to the southwest
let's have a quick look yeah this is one
of her signers favorite routes but
there's no tracks on top of the rain
okay wow it seems like I said Juma have
a bit of catching up to do to find some
cats unfortunately Steve is in the mara
following some lions well I wouldn't
want to be able to beast in this these
conditions we were with the Lions
followed them hunting and then we moved
back into the area and we completely
lost them there they are hiding in the
longer ice is three of them therefore
watch it just pulls our little but
you'll see there's a third one to the
left there's probably a fourth one where
is it there we go there's a third one
moving and there's a fourth one
somewhere there we were with the pride
earlier via we know pride from the
lioness one of them was hunting and it's
a beautiful part of two adults and three
youngsters the young male we followed he
ran all the way back he suddenly after
the attempted wildebeest hunt he ran all
the way back and we thought well
something's going on why is he running
and within maybe he just got a furious
look from one of the Buffalo that were
hanging down in the little little mud
wallow area and you decided hang on I'm
not gonna stick her hunt and here we are
we found three females and they are
sheltering a little bit from the wind
the wind it does make everything
uncomfortable but quite amazing that
does of all the best that we were with
just before how relaxed they are off to
being chased in the mountain bubble go
what an interesting question you want to
know where animals go when it rains well
there's nowhere to go bubble girl
exactly where you see them now is
exactly where they go sometimes the
ruminants like the lobbyists and giraffe
and Buffalo they're like all the rains
come in they'll tuck themselves up and
sit down on the ground so they can have
a nice dry patch but quite often they
just stand there in the rain there's
nothing that can do in Lyons you'll see
them get very miserable in very very -
torrential downpour rain even baboons
will just sit in a tree just
it don't really have anywhere to go
unfortunately so they'll just be exactly
where they are in the sunshine they'll
move on any trees but the likelihood of
certain animals spending time under
trees in these environments is tricky
because lightning is a reality Archer
and those animals that tend to move to
the cover of trees in lightning storms
well sizzle pop and they're don't breed
because being hit by a lightning bolt in
a tree while invariably doesn't leave
too much in the way of a living animal
afterwards hello Rosalinda well the
black tuft on the back of the tail as
well as the black on the back of the
ears makes it easy for the youngsters or
the prior themselves to follow them we
spent some time with the Lions before
and as you look from behind that's all
you can see really as they move through
the tawny grass and when they're looking
in a direction you can see there's no
real interest now their ears are kind of
moving backwards and forwards but when
they look like you can see now looking
in a specific direction the adults or
the others in the hunt can actually see
the exact direction by the positioning
of the ears that that animal is moving
and then they're know exactly what
animals trying to hunt the same goes for
the tail Cubs can also follow the tail
and when a lion is about to charge they
flick their tail up and that's a very
obvious sign in the tawny for a brown
grass of an imminent movement of the
adult lioness moving forward so on
leopards lipids also got the black
behind the ear but then they've got that
white tip on the tail which the Cubs
used to follow through the long grass
and sometimes is so much they have to
play with and bite it but that is a
young step and one of the young females
on the right hand side probably a year
and a half old and there is one of the
adults I'm not sure which one is the
mother there was another young step in
the pride a very pale lioness who
unfortunately didn't make it and we
haven't seen her since last year late
last year but we were quite certain that
something was going to happen earlier
that lioness did everything or I
actually used the rocks to her advantage
she really got close to a herd of
unsuspecting lobbyists and well it was
not to be okay well we going to stay
here with these lions and while we do
that let's go back down to Tristan okay
well we're going to stay there's a
technical issue with the Tristan and the
bushwalk team so you're stuck with me
for the moment you can see the
coloration of the body as they get older
lioness starts to sort of fade a little
bit in the in the coloration you see the
difference between those two in
coloration and one of the writers a
little bit more sort of sort of brighter
in color hasn't been washed as many
times but that one in the middle is
actually the young male now my word how
confusing was that he's joined back
again he ran all the way away and his
back you can actually see he's just got
the little bits of making of fur on the
bottom of the neck and he is a pale in
color probably his sister was the pale
female that disappeared he is not the
brightest
he's been washed too many times but
quite often you can tell a difference in
age due to the coloration and this young
boy he's got a very bad wound on his
back hip le there are a couple pods
around with Cubs the paradise pride has
got some Cubs that are probably between
the ages of 6 and 8 months these are the
youngest that this pride has got and
normally the the Cabot interval is about
two years or so so there's still a few
months away from new Cubs being brought
into the pride and I haven't seen any
males with this with this pride the
Lions though are all over the place at
the moment it's very hard to get a
handle and who there are not far away
just just as over here we've had the Ala
lure ID we've had other males I haven't
seen before the sausage tree pride as a
bit further down but they are moving
because the food is just abundant so the
Cubs at the moment the sausage tree
pride which is much further south
they've got two very smaller ones that I
haven't yet seen and there's been a lot
of mating going on in there pride in the
last couple of weeks but we haven't seen
anything new in regards to that but back
over to these beautiful lions the long
grass I would love to show you some Cubs
we have been searching for the sausage
tree pride but we
yet had any luck anyway while we watch
these lions getting a little bit on the
move let's go back down to Bushwick team
that's got elephants on foot so even
though we're out on foot and we are
trying to find tenganan
sauna and tündi and all the likes that
we get down here in Zuma sometimes well
Nature throws different things at you
and so we've bumped into a massive herd
of elephants that is spread across the
landscape at the moment and it's really
been a phenomenal kind of last few days
as we've had lots of Amy's around and
that's made Bush walk well highly
entertaining and so I'm hoping what we
can do is try and just get a little bit
of a view of easy and he's obviously
quite far away at the moment so it just
bumped into them and they spread out
feedings with his elephants all over the
place now the reason we came down this
way was to try and see if we could help
Brent after the husana as well as to
check if there's any signs of ting Ghana
he often likes to walk down these kind
of drainage sections and so we thought
it would be a good place to come and
have a look it's gonna be obviously very
tricky with the rain that fell about 45
minutes ago to find many tracks but you
never know what's going to happen and so
this is kind of prime sort of
opportunity to well to do an approach on
the jelly's now Massey what have I heard
about Tandy and Columba I haven't heard
much to be honest I mean I wasn't
driving for a few days and it seems as
though Tandy and Columba have moved off
into Torchwood which we know that they
do from time to time and maybe with the
conditions that we've had you know we've
had overcast grey wintry kind of feel to
it and it's been a bit of rain and even
wind that's generally prime conditions
for our cats to be hunting and so I
wouldn't be surprised that tündi managed
to grab herself a really substantial
meal and that's why her and Trey Lambert
stayed on the tortured side for the kind
of most of the the end of the week and
into this weekend so that's where I
think they are at the moment but no
one's actually reported seeing them
since we saw her with that Dyke Aquila
round she asked damn area and when she
kind of had that interaction with husana
but she's around I'm sure I'm short
Columbus just fine we know with Tandy
she can hit off into those areas and
spend a lot of time that way it's also
not a bad place to be looking for her to
be honest if she is back on the move
this is the kind of extreme
Terry and given that it did rain we
should start to see our cats moving
about to remark territory so ting gana
should be fairly active Tammy would be
active should do all of the kind of
territorial individuals should be moving
around and actually marking so where we
are now is a great place not only for
Ellie's to kind of see on foot but it's
also a great place for us to be tracking
and to be looking for any signs of our
cats right so we're going to move off a
little bit we're going to try and see if
we can get a better view of these
Eddie's and check the drainage line
where they're feeding and while we do
that though and it sends you back across
to Jamie who's on the lookout for the in
comer bride well at least it managed to
find a good view of Elly's that we
haven't managed to find our lions yet
and unfortunately I think I've crossed
her beyond our borders I've just done a
quick loop and I can see some very very
fresh buffalo tracks all that stormy
weather I said that Lions don't like it
and they don't really they like to
shelter from rain but if there's an
opportunity to hunt that weather suits
them down to the ground because the
disorientate s-- they prey and it makes
their job is slightly easier this
morning we were with the Inka Hummers
and they were looking quite full bellied
but as though they could still eat a
little bit more it was a far cry from
their almost entirely flat stomachs two
days ago
we managed to find a tin Karuma lions
lazing in a shady spot of the dry druid
relaxed and resting
they were clearly quite hungry and the
sub-adult Cubs displayed some curious
behavior settling into a cub like
suckling position as darkness fell and
the weather worsened the pride set off
through the darkness towards some
Buffalo but not before an evening drink
catching Buffalo is thirsty work so the
good news is that they did manage to
catch themselves something we don't know
exactly what it was because by the time
we found them here this morning they had
already finished us and all that was
left were a few hungry looking hyenas
hanging around the outskirts I found
fresh buffalo tracks over here and I
think I heard some oxpeckers if I were
to guess I would say that these lions
are hidden off somewhere in the bushes
the most interesting thing about that
particular sighting was the suckling
behavior from it wasn't quite true
suckling but the sub-adults settling in
up against their moms belly or Ference
belly potentially it was very it was
fascinating behavior because they really
are far past the age where the females
would be lactating or when they'll be
suckling but obviously old habits are
die hard and those instincts are still
partially engrained in their minds
although it would have been completely
fruitless to try and suckle maybe it
brought them a little bit of comfort
maybe with the separation because of
course they should be 11 members of the
pride plus three males now this morning
there were eight females around here and
one of the mangani males I've heard tell
after the morning Safari that there are
still there the missing members of the
pride are on a giraffe kill with the
other mangani male and the mystery young
male that's joined them so but tricky to
keep track of all the things that are
happening in early in Kahuna's lives
right now just listening hoping i'm itis
would have hear the sound of buffalo
moving through the thick vegetation now
Marcel here's the interesting thing
about the in Kuma's those sub-adults
are almost at the stage where their
mothers are ready to start mating again
some ourselves wondering how often lions
breed the Inka homers will be ready to
mate again the Cubs are about two years
old they'll be ready to mate again very
very soon possibly in the next few
months so with lions you're looking at a
birthing interval of around about every
three years if they manage to raise
their cubs to adulthood obviously if the
Cubs are killed for whatever reason the
females will come back into Easter
sooner and they will then get pregnant
before their three-year interval and it
really depends in this case three of the
five in Coahoma adult lionesses three of
the five yes that's great three of the
five have Cubs that are now nearly fully
grown actually sub-adults
no no luck I'm gonna keep listening
hopefully we get lucky but unfortunately
I think the Inka Hummers have gone
beyond where we can follow while we
figure that out Steve has had more
success up in the Mara and he has
managed to find a lovely lion pride to
spend time with
we are with them and they're trying
again for those wildebeest folks we're
just gonna try and get into a position
so we can see just ahead of us yet is
the lioness because he's stalking once
again she's hidden behind the rocks
this could be what we've been waiting
for the whole afternoon we were parked
here a little while ago and we lost the
lines some are on our art inside I'm
just gonna stop by this rock and there
she is
in front of us they bother Rock there
there's a second youngster joining her
and look at her body language you know
second one about to come join it from
behind but while we wait for action to
unfold talking about Lions with
youngsters and the Paradise Pride loves
the marsh
the paradise pride seemed content in the
marsh area a swampy field of tall and
lush green grass dotted with muddy
wallows and small streams this area is a
theraphy as it runs along the Mara River
and tracks gain throughout the year the
Paradise pradd have found the perfect
place to rear their cubs
so the bountiful area of the marsh
provides a beautiful grazing or year
round and it's a pure perfect place if
you want to rear Cubs with lots of
animals moving through and the marsh
pride the paradise pride themselves my
apologies were eating of all the BS that
day that we found them as is under the
menu for all of the Lions these days
what happened there I think she suddenly
didn't realize her sister or her
daughter was so close behind I think
there might be two youngsters in fact in
the front where are the adults we don't
know we are keeping our eyes very well
peeled because they're not far away at
the moment look at the intention have a
look at the body language they are the
Valda pierced Rama to the paradise pride
being out in the open Marsh there they
have quite a nice selection this time of
year yes there's lots of all the Bears
and zebra moving through but throughout
the year there's topi Impala all sorts
of other small animals such as warthog
are moving through and they quite enjoy
whatever is on the cards in fact and
because there's such abundance of prey
and well there's no need to be too
choosy but this time of year just with
the abundance of all the best they tend
to be the number one food on offering
whether they tasted the best and whether
it's just the abundances it seems to it
is a debate now well across the African
continent in the savannas due to the
abundance of all the best they do form
the majority of lion diet in the lion
diet but down in South Africa well we
see boomer bride thoroughly enjoy his
Buffalo when they can kuru impala and
honestly of all the best when they're
available but their numbers are very low
down there
have millions of all the best as they do
appear the lobbyists are a little bit
alerted we don't know what's going to
happen and this is all coming to live
folks and we spend some time with this
prior to earlier seeing for something
quite similar to what you see not and
unfortunately nothing came about it but
where the adults are I think that is the
money wherever they are and maybe these
youngsters know exactly where they are
well maybe the adults are watching from
a distance to see how these hungry
youngsters are going about it because a
small pride like this only really needs
to feed once a day and because they are
not too many of them but anyway Tristan
Dix down in South Africa is hot on the
search for a sauna we are on the search
for cats but we are surrounded by a
massive herd of elephants at the moment
they say Lee's absolutely everywhere and
so we've just set still now because it's
not really much we can do at the moment
we move off in any directions so we're
just kind of sitting in and just
enjoying and of these guys as they
slowly start to move around us we've got
an elephant that's off on our right hand
side there's one straight in the middle
in will straight in front of us it's
going to make an appearance fairly
shortly it's coming straight towards
where we are absolutely phenomenal to be
on foot say but you see this one here in
front it's coming right towards us this
is amazing now this morning I had an
incredible sighting of elephants on foot
and it seems as though we're about to
repeat the performance because he's a
knees up all over the place this
afternoon really is quite special to be
a ranch and of course remember Elly's
can be very very dangerous and you've
got to be able to aware of what you're
going to get yourself into in your
around a musical always make sure that
you kind of aware of your surroundings
and that doesn't apply only for us out
here our cats also sometimes have to be
aware that there's dangers that they
face too in their environment
while for the most part life at the top
of the lipid hierarchy is a comfortable
one for an agent in Ghana they are
higher versatile perils we must face to
carry on his rule of this unforgiving
land under a team territorial control
the Duke unknowingly walked straight
into one of the other local male lines
luckily ting ganas saw the crouching
male line laying in wait in the nick of
time and stopped in his tracks moment
seemed to last forever the cats weighed
up their options until eating ghana
decided to make a break for it Tirana
made a clean break we live to fight
another day
wasn't that a close call for the Duke
you really did kind of see that line at
the last minute and luckily that he did
because otherwise he would have gotten
himself into a bit of trouble I think
he's was a very fortunate that he walked
into one of the avert Camille's with the
limp rather than actually walking in to
the ink uma pride which would have been
undoubtedly meant he would have got
chased and so he only needs to be quite
careful it's a peril of being I'll
cherish that lions are not friends with
lipids and so to get that close to a
lion and not really see it until the
last second could have been very
dangerous for him had it been like I say
more than just the one and had it been a
fitter stronger healthier lion it
definitely would have made life a little
bit more tricky for him
had it been that case but an amazing
sighting that we managed to witness it
really was super special to be able to
kind of see him moving around and just
to see how he all of a sudden kind of
bumped in to that line was really quite
something now while he's closed in and
get a little closer it seems like Steve
he's got his lines and they also are
getting closer to the prey that they are
busy stalking
they are watch close to the bottom of
the screen that little black bump look
underneath that they regurge the left
they are the ears I was talking about no
that's how the other line is follow them
the intention the body language points
out an individual that that lioness is
looking at and then the rest play their
part by seeing what angle are they
moving and then try and position
themselves in the right spot so as to
assist or catch anything that might run
in a different direction very very
important
that's how Lions have evolved on a
landscape to build to take much larger
prey then they can individually is
working as a unit and they've been
waiting for these Valle de beers - calm
down again and to relax and they're
starting to bed down she's using her
cover there's a youngster in that sort
of middle right of the screen there the
Lions will always try and select the
easiest trying to bring down a young
Valle de base is much easier than an
adult that's through probably twice even
three times the weight so always try and
select something and then well in the
chaos that ensues if they catch
something else well they'll take it
Marcelle yes liens are regarded as I was
threatened at the moment due to the fact
that they're disappearing in places
across the African continent due to
their sort of what's the word their
interference in livestock with people
and also due to the fact that there is
an enormous industry in the East talking
about Tiger bones and Tiger bones
something in traditional medicine in the
east and there's a lot of people that
are hunting lions in Africa and then
selling their bones off as Tiger bone so
the market the price is enormous so
lions are disappearing at an alarming
rate the numbers are going down down
every year only in these massive
reserves are they still in a really good
really good Nick but let's have another
look a second lioness she started moving
off to the right she's kind of picked up
on her sister's idea she see how she's
now looking to the right hand side due
to the change in body language
now folks bearing in mind Lions have got
a success rate of probably 20% or less
when it comes to hunting and these to me
appear to both be youngsters so their
success rate or even lower Kathy I'm not
100% sure how close they are I'm gonna
have another little look now but I'm
reckoning probably less than 50 yards at
the moment they would like to the one on
the left anyway there's a little bit of
a bump there she might try and go down
that bumping up the other side but it is
difficult to actually in this terrain to
see exactly how far away they are we
thought there are much closer earlier
and then when we saw that young lioness
finally make that run it took before
ever to cover that ground and well by
the time she got into a near the veld
abyss that was well and truly out of
reach she's looking back to see if
there's any assistance off to the left
there might be another lioness we don't
know where that third one has gotten to
she might have moved around to the left
and these two might be standing where
they are due to the fact that one might
try and chase them back it does happen
you've seen it in South Africa with the
drone in the air you get a nice aerial
view of the lion hunting this is all
completely
nonverbal communication between the
lines they know exactly what they want
to do and through experience through
mother and daughter and pride dynamics
these sort of traits are passed down see
she's looking to the left as if there
might be something there we can't see
but might be one like that in the grass
I've been scanning with my binoculars
number one tool is a guide in the Mara
Plains you need binoculars hide if they
are so camouflaged I mean we came back
to the scene where we knew there were
and we drove past then that's how
camouflage they are and can you imagine
being of all the beasts well there's so
many of them I suppose it's quite a
common affair our chair but the
objective is to to keep that distance
between the Lions and being in a large
herd like this they've all the best
think they're safe they always think old
Joe or Bob's watching or maybe Sarah's
watching but unfortunately when they're
in a bigger herd like this that it
generally hot easier to catch cuz that
well there she goes she's making a move
on the right hand side the one on the
left has disappeared
okay well as soon as the action and
fault you'll come right back to us but
Brent Leah Smith is tracking he would
like to find a cat for himself
well I wish I was tracking Steve over
one needs tracks to track we haven't
managed to find any just yet so I'm just
Anna a big loop and I saw the elephant
head that Tristan is with so we cut
further to the west
maybe her signer came up towards this
area but so far I've just been seeing
lots of relaxed Impala and that's about
it really I think what we were gonna do
is head back towards where Telex s maybe
they saw us on a little bit further away
from quarantine from where we left him
this morning hmm
he's probably just sleeping somewhere
close by to camp so definitely one of my
favorite spots on on Juma looking down
this valley can you see what I've seen
in the valley Dave I see an elephant
death to the right slightly there we go
looks like a young bull all by himself
now it's always good to stop while
you're on safari and listen carefully to
see if we hear any alarm calls to
signify the presence of a predator and
hopefully the specific predator we're
looking for what's on it okay let us
meander on keep checking for our little
chief and while we do that it sounds
like Devore's lions on the move
thanks bread good luck that side well
the lioness the one that was on the
left-hand side focuses closed the gap by
about 20 odd yards 20 meters she's just
behind the rock now of all the B I still
have not looked at it her sisters move
Dimitra to ford and gone flat but she's
trying to figure out where is mum like
mum what I do now last time I got into
this position I failed now give me some
help so there's the other sister and you
see they're looking around questioning
me look at the cameraman surprised again
are you ready are you guys ready I'm
gonna go now so she's trying to pick out
probably one of the individuals in that
small group that are the smaller of the
of the group and they've all got their
backs to them about 20 yards or so I
actually would like to I'm gonna invest
in the rangefinder so that next time I
could tell you for sure how far away the
lion is from the animals
it's gonna go around that way over the
rock let's have a look hello Paula one
lioness could bring down a bull the best
one lion male definitely but sometimes
if they're if they're young or
inexperienced they might not quite have
the sort of Judo what's the judo sort of
flip that enables him to pull them to
the ground
there's a technique involved they can
jump onto them and slam them across by
pulling their body and because the
dewclaw which is high up on the wrist of
the lion
those will wrap around with the front of
the claws being sort of a nice 90 degree
angle and they're able to pull an animal
off their feet by using their weight and
that putting them off-balance but a big
male of all the best
if lioness runs at it and jumps just on
the bump it might not be able to pull it
down easily but sometimes by doing that
you can slow it down and enable a second
line is to come in and surveil a grab it
by the neck because the thing is to jump
on a Valle de beast that's got horns on
the top of their head they're able to
use those horns to good effect and well
they could penetrate skin make a damage
an eye and let's see what she does
younger lioness hasn't moved it's in the
same position she seems like she's
picking out an individual James Richard
they are completely spoiled for choice
and we draw for the landscape on a daily
basis and there are vultures picking at
bones I don't know how many of all the
beasts have been taken but it doesn't
seem to even dent the numbers okay look
how she's disappeared now we'll just
have to keep our eyes peeled on around
that rock this is where patience really
comes in the male lion is eventually
decided to get up and join the for a
monic I mean I think that's possible
there's that young female and the young
male is eventually coming up towards the
right over here I don't know where the
adults are they didn't take any sort of
effort to there's the young male I
didn't take any effort in the initial
hunt but there might be in here
somewhere there might be have gone all
the way around and I'm actually about to
push these volunteers back towards these
youngsters who don't quite have the
technique of stalking and getting too
close so they're very good at jumping
and holding onto things and there's the
boy have a look at his back left hip
he's got a very bad wound over there but
his belly is quite full because being a
boy regardless of our all do you always
eat more
the ladies doesn't matter what species
you are I suppose he's finally making
his way in that lioness that was
stalking in the beginning she's moved to
just slightly to the left of the rock
NASA she hasn't made another move as
this male gets himself into a possible
ambush position means the lioness over
there she's gonna go round up maybe she
has seen something interesting she's
obviously gonna go over the little hill
that we can't see isn't she Archy that's
how it works she's using the rocks for
cover this is so awesome to watch folks
and forget to send through any questions
and comments you might have wonder if
you can hear how windy it is really does
make a big difference in the Lions
approach okay well are we going to move
up and see if we can get into a better
position for this hunt and while we do
let's go back down to Tristan and his
elephant well good luck Steve we at the
moment unfortunately you're sitting a
dead storm that's because with what a
boo elephant that his sneaky talk to us
and his I would say probably in about
ten meters from where I'm sitting at the
moment the thing is is that he's feeling
his way slowly but surely closer and
closer and so I mean just sitting did
still in the hope it he is going to kind
of find his way out of the sital
drainage line otherwise he's going to
walk right in front of us which will be
quite something so I can't really move
anyway their problem is is we've got
another elephant behind us so okay and
it is stuck in here at the moment which
is well not the worst thing at all I'm
quite enjoying it but you say any time
spent with Enys is a good time indeed
and we have been so spoilt in the last
few days we've had epic epic elephant
encounters on foot it really is thanks
to you too Rex and you know who
obviously gets us into these incredible
places time in and time out and you know
we've had these most amazing uh no
sightings between all of us you know
Brent and Damien
myself it's been quite something but
this afternoon is shaping up to be a
beautiful one is this little bit of
golden light it's just starting to come
out from time to time and it against the
sort of darkness of the LEDs that are
still wet from the rain it is really
quite something so it's turning and
shaping to be a magical magical sighting
we store so it's not a bad thing that we
sitting like this because it allows us
to be in the central part of the
property where we can hear very very
well you must remember that with the
rain tracking has become very difficult
but if we sitting dead still we can hear
noises all around us and that means that
if any of our cats are mobile moving we
won't be able to pick up the noises and
pick up the alarm cause if they can seem
by let's say a bush buck or an Impala or
something like that and be able to then
work out where they are so sometimes
being stationary is not the worst thing
at all and especially given where we are
we so central to the kind of whole area
that we can pick up anything on either
side of us and be able to follow up on
it and hopefully we have some success so
it really is a good spot that we are in
so you know sometimes you will find any
heard so emerge under certain conditions
it's not always only dry seasons but dry
seasons is what a time that you do see a
lot of any hoods
I'm coming around to certain water
points particularly Oh bless you it's
what happens when you get some mud up
your nose and I think it's just blowing
off a little bit of the mud that's kind
of collected it is very muddy I'm pretty
sure when I stand up from here I'm going
to look like I've soiled myself because
I'm sitting on the mud and I can feel it
slowly seeping the witness and it's
really sleeping in my pants which is not
very pleasant at all that you can see it
is a kind of dark dark mud which is
going to be quite something when I stand
up so please don't laugh with me when
you see me from behind
during the course of this afternoon when
we walking around a little bit later I'm
pretty sure you all will anyway but you
can see that this area is a big person
the thing is this very is now it really
isn't any way for him to go up that Bank
he's going to have to either go the way
he came or he's going to follow the bank
around and is a pathway that's just off
to my left hand side that runs right
here and so that would probably be the
pathway that he would have to use or
he's going to come along the front where
there's a lot of pathways a movement of
IMI's that has taken place and so it's
kind of this was the area that he's
going to be with perfectly safe where we
are we're on this Pacific that I'll tell
my mom that he won't be able to get up
even if he tried to climb up here he
wouldn't have any chance and so we just
have to sit there quiet and just kind of
enjoy this sort of beauty of being you
know amongst an elephant herd it really
is quite something
it was amazing though how quickly we got
in the monks thing because we kind of
saw them in the distance and we walked a
little bit and all of a sudden there was
just in he's popping art every way
around us and it can be a kind of one of
the things about being arts and the
bushing when you're on foot is that
you're going to be a bit careful
sometimes that everyone thinks Amy's
making lots of noise but sometimes they
can be incredibly quiet and they can
just pop up kind of right next to you so
he's gonna be aware of those kind of
things right now its uses are in he's
going to come around a little bit
further and so while we kind of wait for
him to see if he's going to come this
way he's just going to stop the infeed
so we began to see while we kind of wait
for him to get here let's send you back
across to Steve who's stool with the
Lions and who are still trying to hunt
that is a filthy beast
well the vault beasts are slowly moving
away as they're feeding and this one
young lioness seemingly out of reach at
the moment is getting big then it slowly
feed as they move away she's in such a
good position behind that really big
rock and see the characteristics on the
back of her let me give away her edge so
inquisitive a great time to sing in fact
that's maybe why the adults are no it's
be seen they're letting them practice go
again you go catch some food oh here we
go
she's gonna show us how it's done she's
been waiting for you to before she shows
us the shows well from our stork let's
go back down to Juma with Jamie who's
got some action I'm terribly sorry just
as you came across to us all the way
from the Mara the pole of our roof got
in the way of the stalk that we were
trying to show you that is because it
has been pouring with rain all day so we
put the roof on only for the rain to
stop because that's obviously how what
makes it stop raining is to be prepared
for it though the search for the Inka
Houmas continues it doesn't sound as
though any of the other guides have had
any luck so what I thought we would do
is we'd come and check at the waterhole
and there's nothing here we're going to
continue on around towards the hyena den
but in Tristan is a sneaking closer and
closer to a Nellie
come right past the mound and it's just
walking right next to us okay that is
unbelievable that is as close as you're
ever going to get to a wild elephant on
foot and believable look at that not
quite right there is nothing like
looking ten in his eye on special
minutes a meter in front of you and
staring at the same ilvl as you are it's
quite something sir that was very very
very special that elephant he put his
trunk out and almost touched this tree
that's right here in front of me so
that's how close he actually came if you
look down below you can see where his
foot was down at the bottom of the base
of the mound and he kind of just walked
past and he's still not a hundred
percent sure about where we are what
we're actually doing he kind of walked
past and out of the corner of his eye I
think he realized hang on a second
there's actually somebody sitting Roger
but he didn't really understand what it
was and that's why he kind of just
pivoted like that and sort of looked at
us and it's now gone around the side and
it's still feeding so that was just
unbelievable it's really very seldom
that you're going to get to see
something like that it's seriously quite
special to be in company of these guys
the rest of the Indies are still coming
so there's a bull and a cow and a calf
that are slowly coming through the
drainage line at the moment hitting in
our direction once again so it's gonna
be a little while unfortunately until we
can move well I say unfortunately but
I've thoroughly enjoyed kind of being up
here we had a really brief view of a
little baby as well trying to play on
one of the banks and climb its way up
which was very entertaining just when we
saw you guys last time and so that's the
one is also around somewhere in this
general vicinity but that was seriously
seriously special it's one of those kind
of once in the sort of lifetime
sightings that you're gonna get rainy
and he's going to get like that with us
and really is quite something and it
just goes to show that if you quiet and
you sit very restful and you load on
that any's will walk past and you can
see that he was not aggressive towards
us in any way and
kind of throw anything at us it didn't
trumpeter didn't mock charge it just
realized him on something's watching me
from this Bank I can't really get to it
it's not being aggressive towards me and
then it just walks off and around it
super super special to get something
like that on what it really is one of
those incredible moments good
now we're gonna slice a if you have to
sit and be patient these aliens are
still all around us and so while we are
patient let's change you back across to
Steve and the owner la pride yes
wellness female stood up and well I'm
gonna say she was spotted by our angles
wildebeest on the ridge of all the BS on
the plane all spotted and all have moved
off to what now seems a very out of
reach position but that is sometimes
what Lions try and do is cause this kind
of confusion get the herd to run in all
different directions and well maybe they
were run into the right action there is
one line or two lying up in the right
position sometimes it's well worked out
and sometimes it's just pure luck but
there she is see if you can spot it eyes
of wildebeest are very very good they're
looking for the shape of lioness and she
stood up and gave their characteristic
sort of Lion shape with ears we look
forward push walk look in the grass of a
lion lifting its head over the grass you
see the shape of the ears and they had
where's she going maybe she's thinking
that the confusion of the herd on the
slopes might provide her with an easy
meal a good time practicing
okay well we're gonna move up and see if
we can catch up with her on the move and
let's go back down to Brent who's still
on the search for the chief well we are
still on the search for a track a track
of any Leopard at the moment maybe they
took advantage of that rain and all
caught themselves a snack but I'm
confident we've still got some time to
find some cats plenty of cats around
this morning
not this evening so far but of course
we've been really really lucky having
her sauna basically very close to camp
and spending a lot of time around
quarantine and Gallagher and he's been
quite successful in his hunting around
the pans but every now and then I saw
Anna's
eyes get too big for his mouth and he
has to think twice before attacking
hasanah was found showing great interest
in a large male walk on the quarantine
clearings he however changed his mind
quickly after he got a look at those
menacing tusks our little chief has
quite a bit of Greg to do yet before he
can take on such a hefty Pig discretion
proved to be the better choice and he
moved off to the shade for a catnap
in time I'm sure Messiah is going to
become a great big hunter but a big male
warthog like that oh it's a bit too big
firm at this edge I think once he's
about mmm five four or five and you
should be able to take on those big pigs
like 10 Ghana and hooker Marie both love
a good wall talk
hello Deborah Deborah is wondering how
we decide the name of the Leopards so
different reserves have different naming
protocols what we do is generally we
will choose a bunch of names
normally in Shangaan it's longer which
is that in local language here and we
will take them to Rickson and Aubrey and
tax and Herbie and we'll have a
discussion and then the name that we
think is the best is then chosen now and
again it depends that's how we do it if
the Leopards are born on Juma on the
neighboring reserves whoever finds the
Cubs first gets naming rights or if
they're found by a guide from another
lodge but I found on let's say Chitra
for example and the chitwa guides will
have the naming rights quickly across to
tristan past us now we're gonna keep
very quiet as they do and you guys can
listen to the sounds of these dailies
coming past it really is quite
spectacular she might stop for a little
feed first she starts to move our way I
will start to keep quiet in order to not
disturb her too much but she shouldn't
theoretically follow the same path which
will be around the bend and in in front
of us but this is just too epic
that is as good as it gets on a walk I
can say we put a little baby le that's
busy trying to learn how to use its
trunk your carts trying to pick up the
little branches isn't that cool
well Rachel yes I mean they have got
sensory cells in their feet and even
though their babies they can still pick
up potential danger around them but the
mother will be far more susceptible to
it and defend that one as one is even
older cough that all the cough will also
come to the aid of this fertile one and
so it's more up to them than it is the
baby sitter take danger around them but
yes it does have the sensory ability to
pick those up and to be able to do what
it means to do to say nice and safe but
look at this one digging for roots now
that any day some adults if you look on
all its tummy you'll notice that there
is actually a little abscess that is
going on it's tummy at the moment I
don't think it knows what to make of us
on this map
that she wants to actually eat and so
she has just stopped a little bit the
baby will be fairly min or about maybe
you'll see will move quite a bit and
that's because you'd obviously can't
feed the same way the adults are you
cute is that cute kids and like I said
all of the sort of foot is very very
very special we are being spoilt more
than I can even tell you this has got to
rank as probably one of my best elephant
on foot experiences that I've ever had
and I've been fortunate in that I've had
a lot in many parts of Africa this is
seriously one of the most amazing
experiences particularly if that female
comes past so they usually are so cute
it is a very very cute you know very
cute now what is wrinkly is one of our
other ones that we saw the other day
beautiful
right now because this is so special we
are going to take this to a wider
audience
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
South Africa as you can see we've got a
herd of elephants a mom and her baby
they saw straight across from us we're
out on a bush walk and we have some
managed to bump into these guys and get
the most incredible view of them as they
walking across the bank it is seriously
seriously special we are coming to you
live like I said and that means you can
interact with us so you can you post any
questions you have in the comment
section below but there's a little baby
that's charging around now mom is just
making sure little one is safe it's a
bit of a wind that's just started to
swell so you see now she's picked up our
scent and she's just looking in our
direction
just making sure that her baby is nice
and safe and making sure that it gets
away well Michael we are trying to make
friends obviously we want to be a little
bit careful with the news Cassini's can
be seriously seriously dangerous animals
on foot but luckily what we've got is
we've got ourselves into a really nice
position where we kind of on a very
steep Bank where the alias won't be able
to get to us there's a nice bit of space
between us and them and so at this stage
everything is okay and we can make
friends but she seems to have relaxed
now she might have caught a bit of a
sentient and then trying to kind of
shift her baby off a little bit but now
that she's digging for roots and feeding
that is a sign that she's completely
kind of comfortable with what's going on
she wouldn't stop and feed with her baby
so close if she was worried now
sorry Emma if you can just repeat that
for me
Haley says she is a Big Mama she's not
the oldest female that I've seen our
chair nor the biggest but when you are
standing less than 10 meters from her or
sitting should I say listen ten meters
from her she is massive and she
certainly has an intimidating presence
and you would not want to cross a mother
elephant there's one thing about Daly's
they might be intelligent but they are
also highly highly protective of their
little ones they will do everything that
they can in order to try and keep their
babies safe and that often means that
they also front up and be quite kind of
aggressive to a threat luckily like I
say for us we are not a threat in any
way we're not being threatening in our
behavior we sitting here with our voice
is quite low we're breaking a very low
profile by sitting up against a mound
and I'm begins to bank where it's not
really a profile that she's picking up
and the wind unfortunately every gnarly
in swirls cuz we've had a bit of a storm
this afternoon and that means that it's
a bit tricky because she sometimes is
picking up our scent more than anything
else but she's relaxed completely now I
mean look at how she's digging out that
root isn't that incredible now these
kind of sightings generally are kind of
reserved for being in a vehicle but for
some reason women spoiled this afternoon
by getting as close as we've managed to
get and now we've even got a bit of
light breaking through into a sort of
bush and it's really it kind of
highlighting the city now unless you say
so lucky you wish that you could be on
foot with us well as we are incredibly
lucky to be able to do this it's one of
those very fortunate things as being our
chair as a guide and probably one of my
best parts of my job is being able to
kind of share this with all of you it
really is a magical thing to be on foot
with with these and I hope that one day
Liz maybe maybe that you get an
opportunity to come out and go on a
guided experience where you can
potentially view a lease on foot there's
very few things like its well there's a
little Dyke in the background behind it
Haley there's a little small antelope
that's moving around as well so I don't
know if it's visible but sort of kind of
bouncing out of it
I'm hoping the little baby Ellie comes
back towards mom it is quite old already
it's not suckling by the looks of things
anymore she certainly is not producing
what amounts of milk which means that
it's probably spending most of its time
it's actually forage for food now and
it's being a bit shy because it's hiding
itself behind they sort of fallen over
the tree but it is the cutest little
Ellie ever it really is very very cute
we had it just now much closer to us and
it was kind of rubbing up on trees and
trying to use its trunk and generally
just being a baby elephant which
typically is a lot of life lots of
energy and a overload of cuteness
Semillon she is keeping an eye on us she
is just aware that there's something
opposite her but she doesn't know quite
what it is and because we're not
threatening she's happy just to feed
like that her baby is not too close to
us and so she's okay to have you know
the little one there and for her to feed
on this area and she's just making sure
that there's not too much movement
across from her that she needs to worry
about so at this stage one is okay her
general body language is very good like
I see an elephant when it's stressed
will not eat it will be very focused on
you her head would be raised her ears
would be out to make herself more
impressive and bigger and you'd find her
tail would be dead straight at the
moment her tail is relaxed it's just
kind of flopping in the breeze every now
and then it's lifting because I think
she's about to go to the toilets at the
moment and then you'll find that her
ears are quite relaxed she's flapping
them and that yesterday is still feeding
so her behavior for now is absolutely
fine she is kind of keeping a close look
on what's going on but she's not too
stressed about I said all I just wish
her little one would come out because
like I said it is the cutest thing but
another Ellie that said she just come
out from the right hand side of us he
walked past us a little bit earlier we
had a little bull young bull elephant
that was a teenager he walked after and
he kind of decided to come say hello and
he's just kind of gone down across the
river bank but this has been a
phenomenal afternoon with our eddie's we
really have been fortunate to be this
close to a tease on foot is probably got
to be one of the biggest highlights of
our garden careers and so very very very
special but it's what we're going to be
doing for now hopefully you've enjoyed
this and if you want to carry on and see
what happens without your knees well we
said yeah you can google safari live but
until next time for myself and Sam it's
been an absolute pleasure
right now our knees are still digging
they still straight across from us this
is just the most spectacular sighting
but it sounds like jamie has caught up
with a cuteness overload
that's awesome Tristan I'm really really
happy for him that sounded really truly
magical speaking of really truly magical
we're enjoying watching one of our
members of the juma clan clean the
bottom of her cub though this is pretty
and we have while we've long suspected
that she has all that she had Cubs we
have only just in this last week
discovered that that is the case and
seen her cover for the first time so we
are at the dew McClendon they've
recently moved here and we have not one
but two little Cubs there we go there's
pretty very easily identifiable and if
you're really lucky if you're really
really lucky you might even have a
chance to see a Corky's cub as well with
it's a tiny little bald patch it's been
popping its head throughout while we've
been sitting here Corky isn't here so
there's two different Cubs from two
different mothers and the mother of the
younger cub isn't isn't at the den at
the moment so while the her cub feels
comfortable enough to come out what it's
been trying to do is actually suckle
from pretty which is very cheeky indeed
because I eanes don't allow Cubs from
other mothers to suckle from them there
are very very limited exceptions to that
rule and the only time it happens only
time it happens is well I'll explain
about it later because interesting
things are happening in the Mara with
Steve let's go and find out ortiz lions
are up to now
yes well this lioness has finally given
up the chase on that herd of all the
best
but then start running back in the other
direction because another hood of all
the beasts came down the mountain from
the other side but her and her two
siblings well they seemed to be left out
in the windy cold with no adults
anywhere to be seen
those two started playing there we go oh
that's what you get for being a big
brother it's all play it's all fun and
games they were climbing the tree a
moment ago now you're probably gonna see
that other youngster get on top on top
of the rock as well
Daniel Lions don't generally run more
than about 50 odd metres off to prey
maybe less maybe more they're gonna play
on top of the rock invariably they want
to get as close as they can but there
are places like in the Kalahari where
their lions actually lie out in sort of
a relay sort of fashion and and chase
the animals and then as soon as the one
line gets tired the next line picks up
the chase but I mean it all depends on
the prey they're chasing all the animals
Archer invariably over distance are much
faster than Liars so if they haven't
caught them in the first 20 to 30 metres
20 or 30 yards well invariably they give
up because there's no chance they're
going to catch them they have great
acceleration out of the blocks but once
the prey animals are alerted to them and
move off while there's no real chance
for them catching so you don't really
see them going much longer than that
cheetah are more of a pursuit specialist
they can go up to almost 300 metres 400
metres even but then after a chase like
that even if they do catch or if there
must they're completely out of breath I
in a wild dog well then our stamina
specialists and they can go on all day
long I'm gonna get some fun here there's
no food but we'll play with each other
there was a perfect take down I was
talking earlier about the vil the best
and how that take down about the judo
slam and that was a very good example of
a judo slam but anyway from our playful
Lions down to
within the little hyena pups oh there's
so much happening this afternoon we
barely know where to look when of course
while you were with Steve and his lines
were being entertaining
Corky's cub came out stuck its head up
and tried once again to suckle from
pretty only to find itself kicked back
into the den I was talking about a low
suckling because it's a really nice
comparison between lions that we were
looking for earlier today and of course
Steve has lions as well in the Mara and
spotted hyenas our spotted hyenas clans
are made up of females that are not
necessarily related to each other
whereas lion prides will be related will
all be related so they'll be sisters
aunts cousins daughters mothers whatever
it happens to be what that means is that
when Lions have Cubs they will allow the
Cubs of another female to suckle from
them if they are lactating
we're in hyenas it doesn't actually work
that way
in the only time you will see a cub
suckling from a female is when it is a
very very high ranked cub that is
forcing or bullying a low ranked female
into feeding it the lower ranked female
only really participates or allows it to
happen because she's scared of
retaliation from the high ranked Cubs
mother I wish you could see a pretty
simple cub it stuck its face up earlier
when it was disturbed by a Corky's cub
and it is the wrinkly it's got the
wrinkly ass little face imaginable it
looks old it's all wrinkled and
concerned with frown lines well since
our hyena Cubs have done such a sterling
job of hiding away from you every time I
want to show them it's give you a little
taste of what you can expect when they
do come out
after moving halfway across Juma to a
new den site Corky's cub was finally out
and about and exploring its new home the
cub very quickly overcame its
nervousness and after a brief breakfast
snack merrily gambled around and over
mum never straying too far from her side
this little face with its perfect bald
patch is destined to warm hearts
heartwarming indeed and at that point
while we knew that pretty had occurred
somewhere we didn't realize that we'd
have double the cuteness at the same den
site last time I saw pretty now I see I
had note I had been informed of this
beforehand she's lost the tip off the
top of her left ear there's a little one
you can just see its little leg tucked
up against it that's its back leg over
there mom has finished attending to its
high genic needs Oh
hygiene is all relative we're hyenas are
concerned before you came across here we
watched a pretty urinate on its head no
everything's relative when you're a
hyena or align well you seen them do
that to their cubs as well I think
Corky's cub has got the message though
it hasn't tried to come out again
Rosalind I'm not sure of the exact
numbers of hyenas in this clan I've been
away for a little while so I haven't had
a chance to do a proper headcount but
you're probably looking at around about
14 or 15 that I can think of off the top
of my head the Juma clan seemed to
suffer a little bit of a setback in the
last year or so
the matriarch madam disappeared she
hasn't been seen for an extended period
of time and is one of the low ranked
females that disappeared as well and in
fact last year was marked last year in
the beginning of this year we mark
by the disappearance of several females
and it's only recently that the dreama
clan has moved their den site back on to
Juma itself which means we can start to
really get an idea of which members of
the clan are still alive or still around
and their relationship with each other
and does the Juma clan have a new
matriarch and who would it be pretty
interestingly enough is a Madam's
daughter so by rights she's one of the
highest-ranking members of this clan her
brother Bella has a probably dispersed I
thinking yes and right and so pretty is
one of the highest-ranking members is
she the matriarch it doesn't seem to be
that way by all accounts Corki seems to
be more dominant than pretty but this is
a perfect opportunity to actually watch
this play out because they're sharing a
den site although Corki and pretty have
always had very cordial relations they
have been they've always been friendly
with each other we've never seen any
grief between them and in fact when we
first got to know them properly they
were sharing a den two years ago when
pretty had November and Corki had D 1
and D 2
oh pretty well here Corky's approach
long before we realized that she's on
her way so we've got to keep watching
her body oh look look look here comes
little patches not official name that is
cookies cub little bit younger than the
cub that is suckling from pretty at the
moment how could how utterly adorable is
that you name to get into trouble your
mom is not here to protect you the hyena
ranking is not necessarily based on size
it's based on psychology so this little
cub if it is if Corky is high ranked
then pretty at this point has to learn
this from its mother so she will by her
behavior teach it where it sits in the
ranking system and it will respond to
that
now if pretty were the matriarch I think
she would have gone for that cub
properly and chested away property I
don't know we'll have to watch and see
how this unfolds but it looks as though
Corky's little one is already learning
from mum and knows that it can push its
luck you're gonna get kicked back into
the hole you're not careful it's quite a
steep entrance at this particular den
site we watched the cub trying to
struggle out or are you hungry it's a
standoff well he's cub really pushing
its limits here while we wait to see who
wins
the bold cub or the adult female let's
find out how brains search for the
little chief is treating him
well at the moment I'm searching for any
Leopard I'm gonna make my way back
towards camp and hopefully husana pops
out around quarantine a little later at
the moment we're just taking in the
beautiful views and this looks like
there might be some more rain on the way
later on this evening you can see the
dark brooding skies to the south but now
why I ponder where husana might possibly
be let's go have a look and what he's
been up to earlier in the week
hisana continues to scent mark with 10
ghana occupied with a new lady from the
north our little chief is testing the
boundaries all of us are wondering if
and when he might start soaring and will
that be the final straw that pushes ting
ghana
to chase the little chief away but for
now it's amazing just to spend time with
the goofy asana as he keeps us
entertained with all his silly antics I
for one will be sad when he moves off to
make his way in the world he is truly
such a special special cat and I'm
hoping we are spoiled with sightings of
lisanna for many years to come I know
that's unlikely but hey we can hope no
we're just gonna sit quietly for a bit
longer here listen to see if we can hear
any alarm calls
yes and brown-headed parrots walking in
the distance can you have horn balls
but none of the alarm calls we're hoping
for
oxpecker flying over
and in the distance okay we're gonna
keep moving now see what else we can
find
hopefully asana is going to make an
appearance before the end of the safari
lives but let's go back to the one hand
with Jaime still with our lovely two
little Cubs not just one oh pretty
finally lost it with the cub with
Corky's cub trying to suckle from her
and now both Cubs have gone into the
hole it's her own cub got a fright as
well a little bit it that was the
wrinkly thing you ever did see
okay oh well the Cubs hurt in theory if
they can manage to get out of the den
let's cut back to Steve who's lions are
also feeling playful on a marvellous
African evening yes well the geology
here doesn't only support the beautiful
Plains of all that's on the landscape
and source a very nice playground for
some young lioness who have been running
and jumping and here we go watch out
it's going to jump off the other side Oh
caught him caught or should I say okay
they've been running and tackling each
other the way they should tackle of all
the beasts it's been quite comical to
watch the boy I ever with his injured
leg has been staying well out of the
action because I think it's just quite
painful in fact
don't know exactly what happened to him
but one of these lionesses up a tree
just now let's write up in the tree
we're gonna have to move up quickly see
if we can get them on the other side of
that big basalt rock just happen to
block our view that is stee colors are a
little bit so faded I've managed to take
up much supplies as we can oh so it
might look a little bit black and white
to you we tried to use in the infrared
light to our light has gone our Sun is
setting in the distance and there's been
overcast for some time and the light is
quite poor on the eye and going into the
realm of darkness with these young lions
where are your parents
or should I say mum and aunt I don't
know they are walking every which
direction they can to try and find them
maybe climbing trees and rocks and
looking off into the distance to see if
they can find a bit so far they have not
been lucky I have no doubt that possibly
the lioness have maybe killed something
when with the other pride not watching
Courtney how all the females well
females can probably make from as early
as about two two and a half but normally
more like around the age of about three
is when they're properly into East hrus
but a little bit earlier can happen the
same goes with males but they're not
generally allowed to mate earlier than
that because they haven't exerted any
dominance so three is pretty much about
the sort of age and males anywhere from
about three up to four is when their
start becoming sort of a little bit more
section yeah obviously they would be
possibly one of the reasons males get
pushed away from a pride straying
interest in their sisters and their
mothers
he loved his from a from a genetic point
of view
okay well as it seems like we might be
losing some signal let's go back down to
Drew maratha me and her favorite animal
the Cubs are really truly or at least
coquí's cub is really truly out and
about now I've decided what Freddie's
cut reminds me off but remind her of a
raisin and he's so rinkie rinkie tiny
and dark in color
Corky's cub didn't need a telling twice
there it's interesting that not a sounds
been made pretty is not making any low
groans of warning hyenas technically
don't growl but they make a very similar
sound - growling when they're across
Corky hasn't once responded that way or
aggressively really she's just kept
lifting her head and chasing the cub
away quite gently for a hyena
cup is comfortable once again Hayden who
is one of our seven-year-old viewers
Aiden it's very exciting that you're
watching the Safari I hope you think the
Cubs are as cute as I think they are now
Aiden would like to know if the mama
hyena will play with the Cubs and yes
she will a little bit but mostly she
just kind of tolerates them climbing all
over her so she just lies still and lets
them treat her like a jungle gym or a
chew toy and basically lets them run
riot around her you know what which
hyenas actually do play Aiden is the
young males and the young females that
have already left the den they like to
come back and play with the Cubs and
they teach them all about being an adult
hyena and how to wrestle and help to
build up the Cubs muscles and sometimes
male hyenas adult male hyenas that are
part of the clan they like to come and
visit the den too and keep the Cubs
entertained and by doing that they
actually make friends with the mothers
as well so it works for all the hyenas
that's why we spend so much time at
these den sites it's because they're
essentially the social hub of the hyena
clan especially when the higher-ranked
females have Cubs the other members of
the clan often come to pay their
respects in my time spent in the Mara
that was how we started off every
evening because we could almost
guarantee that we were going to find the
high-ranked individuals and that all of
the Nights action would start at the den
site itself they took a moment to gather
together to bond to reassert their
dominance
well child of the universe you want to
know if all hyena clans are somewhat
distantly related I suppose yes if you
go far enough back but there's no close
relationship between say the juma clan
and a clan in the southern sabi sand or
a clan on the western edge of jummah
but between perhaps a hyena clan that is
to the north and Mannie laity or perhaps
even the elephant's plain elephant
Plains clan there could potentially be a
familial connection there they might
once have come from the same clan that
splits in two into two sometimes females
don't appreciate their lot in life if
they're low ranked and they sometimes do
move off and start their own clan often
when there's been a death of a matriarch
it creates an unsettled feeling within
the clan that hierarchy may be brutally
enforced but it is also essential to
their stability and security so yes it's
possible that neighboring clans are
related to each other and perhaps if you
go far enough vacuum you would of course
find common ancestors - - all hyenas
remember of course that a lot of the
males actually come from neighbouring
clans so some of the male's that we see
around here that are now part of the
Juma clan could easily have emigrated in
from other clans from neighboring clans
now will no longer spend time within
their natal clan they invest their lives
in their new clan once they're accepted
and they play an enormous role in
helping to defend the clans territory
the male hyena is a crucial part of a
clan life
Jacklyn you want to know how many Cubs
are typically in a clan it's a difficult
one to answer two pins on the size of
the clan I mean it's sort of a little
bit like how long is a piece of string
what you will notice is that although
hyenas breed all year round they do tend
to have Cubs around about the same time
there's usually several sets of Cubs at
a communal den and there's usually a
peak breeding season and that will
depend upon where they are so in the
Mara just after the arrival of the Valda
beast and it's plenty of food and here
in Juma we often see young Cubs of this
age around this time as we go into the
wet season at the end of the dry season
where food is plentiful for the
Predators so it's difficult to say what
would be a typical number for this clan
we've seen three sets of Cubs perhaps
even four sets of Cubs that are communal
than before and a cub generally a female
will be halved between one and two Cubs
I don't think we've had any females with
three cubs it's very unusual for a hyena
mother to successfully keep three cubs
alive to the point that they actually
come out of the den truly peaceful see
she could not look more content
the nice thing of course is that once
her cub is finished having its drink
it's going to want to come out and play
and we'll be here waiting for when it
does meanwhile a Tristan continues his
stroll through the bush let's go see if
he can top that elephant sighting
well we've extracted out of the early
sighting we left there needs to go on
their way which was perfect we got off
nice and easily and there was no issues
and that was absolutely wonderful to
spend the afternoon with them now you
can see it's starting to get very dark
to our South once again is some very big
sort of ominous clouds that are
developing it's been a long time since
we've seen clouds like that around the
jhummer area so hopefully promise of
rain Rick's was actually telling me that
down south and the crew gear on the
Milan area that they actually had a bit
of flooding this afternoon has really
poured with rain down there so let's see
how it goes maybe we going to get some
now we're still trying to find any signs
of any of our lipids we found a track
that looks a little bit old which is not
ideal and so hopefully we'll try and
pick up something a little bit fresher
as we were moving around we're just
checking some of the drainage sections
which would be places really a lot of
our lipids probably would have hidden
during the course of the rain but we
also are in an area where kind of one
for cars eating Ghana husana spent that
time with that kill and it's not really
only been new bales that have arrived
here in G Manuel we've had a few of the
females that we don't know arrived to
the dynamics of Juma's Lepidus has been
one of ups and downs over the last few
years but just as things seem to be
settling a new shy female from the north
has made an appearance for the second
time in the last month her unrelaxed
demeanor suggests her past is one of
very little exposure to vehicles and
life around as humans with a bit of
patience and quiet her fear gave way to
the overwhelming drive to continue her
legacy as she emerged from the thickets
to mate with the Duke
the pair spent the day repeatedly mating
slowly pushing deep into Juma and
tandi's territory her desperation to
make fart way to normal respect of her
territorial boundary with her neighbor
after a second round of mating in as
many weeks one can only wonder if
successful will this female push deeper
and keep her cut as close to their
fathers domain well
isn't that exciting that there is this
shy female around I really hope that we
can spend more and more time with her
over the next couple months and try and
just kind of get her a little bit more
relaxed around vehicle she is definitely
very very nervous she's obviously come
from an area where vehicles were not a
huge part of her sort of previous life
and hasn't had much exposure to cars and
kind of the movement and and those kind
of things and it really took a long time
for her to start to kind of feel as
though she could come out but she was
absolutely beautiful I thoroughly
enjoyed spending time with her she's not
a leopard that we are I had seen before
so it's always wonderful to see a new
leopard and she's beautiful in that
she's very different to our lipids that
we see regularly here the Corolla
lineage tends to have quite gold coats
whereas if you looked at her she had
very light almost translucent kind of
sides to her she was very pretty and in
her kind of face had very expressive
eyes you could see she kind of stay down
a little bit and she's definitely much
older than I think we first gave her
credit for you know when she was first
seen with Taylor mating with Tigana two
weeks ago everyone kind of thought she
was a younger female maybe four three
four years old but I think she's a bit
older than that if you look at the kind
of condition of her face in her ears
there's definite scarring obviously on
the mouth cheese but that scar over the
right sort of part of her mouth and in
that little V out of her left ear
there's a bit of tattooing on the ears
and that would indicate that this animal
is a little bit older there's actually
gone through life quite a bit as I would
say that for me she looks probably
closer towards sort of six years old
five six maybe even seven which would be
interesting I mean it means that she's
hung around for this long without any
one really kind of knowing who exactly
she is which is kind of incredible to me
that
in an area with so populated with
tourism and with vehicles and people
that drive around day in day art that
they can still exist a creature like a
lipid there can be that kind of elusive
and that sort of well hidden in
camouflage that she doesn't get found
very often I think it's absolutely
amazing and so awesome to kind of see
her mating with ting gana
as well obviously it's great that Egon
is an hour potentially could father
another generation he's been so
successful as a male leopard that it
just bodes well for him to kind of carry
on and we'll see what kind of this all
means for the rest of the lineages and
this sort of dynamic within our liquids
here anyway we're gonna keep going we're
gonna try and see maybe we can get a
last-minute leopard in the meantime lo
let's send you back across to Steve who
I think is still with the lines and
hopefully they'll carry on their hunting
well folks jump on board I apologize I
thought I'd mention the pride Rhea worth
was there wieners I defeated earlier in
the unscheduled casts I apologize if I
did mention again the five proud of five
and we're following these three hyena
that have come past the pride at a rate
of knots unfortunately we were in a very
bad signal area there so we won't be
able to contribute so these hyena came
along and they were absolutely motoring
Wow here they are they were doing a bit
of scent marking haven't done any
calling that I can I can tell but
they're smelling their noses to the
ground their tails well that one's not
these tails not up but the other two
have got their tails curled up over
their back and well this could be
exciting something could be unfolding we
don't know what they've smelt what they
can hear but we're now in a move like
this with excitement their tails up
something is afoot they hunting whether
they are going to steal food from
someone whether they are other hyena in
the area that they're going to compete
with it's hard to say
child at the universe is a great
question I think lines regardless of
pride size learn very similar sort of
times the larger the pride the more food
is required so that adults spend more
time hunting smaller prides maybe the
youngsters get more opportunity to
assist but I wouldn't say that at any
stage prize larger or smaller the
youngsters would learn earlier than
other Brad's they they put in the effort
when the time is right and well he's
hyena look how excited they are that
herd of all the best that the Lions were
chasing seems to be the attention but
there's stuff on the ground that they
keep smelling the Bears are moving at a
rate of knots
this is epic we're gonna see if we can
keep up with those I in as they move off
into the distance jump on board bumpy
the herd is massing the huge group of
them coming down from the mountain here
so I didn't quite copy that em Judy
asked a question about something about
dangerous I'd love to answer
Judy I don't think the boulders and
rocks are very dangerous in fact if
anything they provide them with a little
bit of something to elevate on so that
they can see in the distance from a
dangerous point of view nothing really
they're not moving just being very
careful yeah there might be a big hole
in the ground bill the best are being
they are splitting up they are in every
single direction at the moment I don't
know what it's got under their nose have
a look at this coming off over to the
right but while we keep up if we can
find these hyena again let's go back
down to Jamie it seems like her little
puppies or cubs or coming out the hole
just one cub at the moment who briefly
stopped a suckling to have a look at us
and with that natural curious gaze of a
king of a growing hyena cub just can't
quite seem to get comfortable here we go
about a week and a half I would say
older than Corky's cub look at that face
still a little wobbly it'll be
interesting to see how soon these Cubs
learn to come up to our vehicle because
of course they haven't got any older
Cubs to learn from and that's how that's
how it all starts as the older Cubs
teach the younger Cubs to make their way
towards us David no I haven't had a
chance to properly check whether we've
got male or female Cubs here it's a
tricky thing with young Cubs especially
that's why the researchers themselves
will never go off
just one quick assumption as to whether
or not a cub is a male or a female they
have to independently three of them have
to see the Cubs genitals properly and
come to a conclusion and agreement as to
whether or not it is a male or a female
and even then it's still possible to get
it wrong
it is something very very tricky with
hyena Cubs because of course a female
genitalia look very similar to males
this Cubs reached the oversized
ear stage yes that's your mum's ear it's
the perfect Chooch away
okay you don't need to be scared of us
Barbara you want to know if new males in
the area will pose a threat to hyena
Cubs male in Maryland fans aside in
other words males are killing young cubs
is very very rare in hyenas because of
the dominance of females over males even
a male that has made its way into the
clan's territory in the hopes of joining
the clan will not be brave enough to
approach a den and pose a risk to the
Cubs the biggest risks to Cubs at this
age is other adult females particularly
for low ranked Cubs where there are high
ranked females with Cubs at the same den
so sometimes high ranked females lose
their temper with low ranked Cubs if
they get a little bit too boisterous
with their own cubs and they will turn
around and grab the little cub and the
low ranked mothers can't do much about
it they cannot really challenge them so
that is a sad reality of hyena nature
not all females do it though yes indeed
Minah Moo hyenas are one of those rare
mammal species where they are born with
fully or ma'am rare mammal predators
that are born with a fully erupted teeth
exploring always back to the safety of
mum not quite old enough to be too brave
yet so what that means is that when two
Cubs are born to the same litter they
have established their hierarchy before
they even emerge properly from the den
they fight with each other they often
come out a little scarred and scratched
especially when you've got two members
of the same sex so if you've got two
females in a den or two males they will
fight fiercely to establish that
dominance before they even pop out up
see
there is there was a very common very
common story that Sibley side was common
in hyena Cubs that they would often kill
members if you had two females or two
males one would always kill the other in
a display of dominance that's not true
does happen but it is very rare as the
supply side theory has long been
disproved so it's not typical all that
will happen is that the hierarchies
established oh we're still thirsty well
hungry I should say mum's milk is some
of the most nutritious milk over any of
the mammal species I'll come on it's a
raisin or a prune that's ridiculous
very coordinate
play with me mum clay Leigh are you with
me full of energy I've just had the best
meal ever oh look I'm running I'm
running and bouncing Lily
[Laughter]
ouch did you get a bit carried away
there by any chance
fell over it immediately ran to the
safety of the den Lily who is one of our
regular viewers Lily is seven years old
and would like to know when hyena Cubs
will get their colors and the answer to
that Lily is around about two and a half
months to three months old you'll start
to see the spots clearly on the
shoulders then as they get older the
spots become clearer and clearer until
all that's left is little dark feet the
hyena cub is giving us a lesson in the
Grace and agility of hiatus
he's slipping this is a very steep den
this is a positively palatial den that
they're at termite mound with very steep
sides
edan I would love for you to hear the
sounds that the Cubs make because yes
indeed they do make a noise
they make a sound known as a screw
Turing now scootering is a sound that
they make when they're begging for food
and it sounds like they sound like a
baby dinosaur out of Jurassic Park
that's what it sounds like it's a
ridiculous sound
it's a streeting grating and incredibly
loud you can't even believe that a cub
that small could make that much noise so
they have proper Tantrums when they want
food they will also whoop so already at
this age they'll start to imitate adult
behavior and it's so sweet because their
voices aren't adult voices yet they've
still got little baby voices and you
know how hyenas make that contact call I
don't wanna do it too loudly and
frighten the cub but when they little
like this they go it's very sweet - yeah
hopefully the more time we spend with
them they'll actually show us that
they'll give us a demonstration if I
remember correctly pretties come
November used to love doing that
Hidy funnily enough we do actually know
where the rest of the clan or at least
some of the clan members were this
morning they were hanging out around the
Lions all the way to the east of Jummah
we had ribbon we had at ribbons daughter
and tema there were a couple of hi
what's the word again for the the skin
on the elbow I can't remember now that's
what the Cubs trying to chew on pretty
I'm thinking ah but it makes the perfect
chew toy for a hyena cub but hyenas
heinessen a clan don't necessarily all
stay together in one big group
so although the clan will unite to chase
lines or for kill or to chase away rival
clans
they don't they don't stay together all
day so it's not like a lion pride
they'll hang out together in groups or
two or three or maybe five and they'll
go to sleep in fig drainage lines or
underneath bushes but around about now
this would be at the perfect time for
them to be up and about and active and I
wouldn't be surprised if before the end
of theof Safari lives
ouch Corky comes back to feed her cub as
well you are horrible
you are so horrible Vegas cat lover
thank you very much indeed
thank you for that reminder the skin of
the elbow is called
a weenus I'll say no more because that
is what the cub is trying to chew I
watched you fall over your mom's foot at
least five times while we've been
sitting here how are you keep forgetting
that their mom did you moms what is
there
now the only time you'll get to see this
behavior is when one of them one of the
female very difficult to focus on on
making coherent conversation about this
when you've got Cubs doing 360-degree
spins supernova hyenas do not make their
own dents they will actually what did
the Thunder scare you game is that scary
weather
rumble Rumble they will take over old
artifact barrows or old warthog burrows
but the little Cubs will also do a bit
of excavating themselves so you'll see
they've got quite sharp little claws and
they use those to dig their way into
little narrower tunnels to help to keep
them safe because the entrance to the
den is quite wide but it's important
that they have tunnels they can go into
that will help to hide them away from
large animals that could be a threat
including other female hyenas it's also
how they end up with bald patches one of
the big reasons they end up with oh yeah
pretty Mina Moo yes indeed hyenas will
hunt at night or during the day most
often at night because the darkness
suits them creates panic panic panic and
pandemonium with prey species so scary
now I'm going away oh yeah
instinct immediately tells it back into
the safety of the den but hyenas do hunt
during the day most often when it rains
because that again creates a situation
where the prey finds it very slippery
very disorienting and they can use their
stamina to chase down and exhaust the
animals that they're trying to hunt so
remember for our new viewers hyenas are
not scavengers spotted hyenas are not
scavengers it's brown hyenas yes striped
hyenas yes but spotted hyenas are
predators and they mostly will catch
hunt and catch their own food getting a
proper bath from mum despite desperate
efforts to move down further into the
day and away from her tongue as the cute
family scene unfolds I think there's a
good chance that pretty is going to
vanish off which is what husana has done
to branch this afternoon let's see where
he is and if he's had any further luck
with his search while we in little chief
has evaded me today but as we know last
minute towards Gallagher and his
favorites but fingers crossed that we do
get a last minute sighting of our
wonderful little chief
I'm sure he's around here somewhere but
it has been a really great week of
catching up with asana particularly for
me I'm see I haven't spent much time
with them this year so I've had a
thoroughly wonderful time getting
reacquainted with the little sausage not
so little sausage anymore now we still
haven't seen any sign of Tandy and
clamber it so I haven't caught up with
them just yet but I'm gonna go park on
the edge get my ears art and open and
listening hopefully that last-minute
leopard will happen in the meantime
I know Tristan is nearly back at camp as
the Sun is starting to set trying to
mobilize quite quickly back home because
the Thunder is looming very close and
there's some ominous clouds kind of
coming in our direction it's a beautiful
beautiful sky
make no mistake but don't really want to
get caught up in a massive thunderstorm
on foot so we're trying to head our way
back so starting to get very dark now
it's not I would see a place you want to
walk around in the dark and so we're
trying to kind of get that we were still
trying to look out for any signs of
hasana we kind of moving about in the
areas that he likes to walk in the hope
that we might find him somewhere here
unfortunately though I don't see any
sign of him I mean we found some tracks
that were mixing I think it could be him
they are damaged by rain which would
mean that he walked there before the
rain kind of started hopefully but on
top of some of the any tracks that of
the herd that we saw so I think it's him
kind of look like a hitting to also a
treehouse dam that's roughly where it's
kind of looked like I was going but
tough to say anyway we're gonna try and
kind of head back home it's that time
anyway and so while we do that let's
send you back across to Jamie and that
precious little cub it's definitely
going to be dark soon which means for
human beings like Tristan it is
certainly a time to get closer to home
for our hyenas it means time to wake up
and head about their evening business
has almost totally nocturnal creatures
this is when they are at their most
awake we have been treated to a truly
stunning evening with a pretty and her
little cub and a brief of view of
coquí's little one as well this cub is
now prettiest cub is now doing its
utmost to trip mum up it comes dashing
out of the den bites her ankles or her
wrists and then runs back in again it's
an absolute little terror a tiny raisin
with very sharp teeth a terrifying
prospect
a lovely prospect is the knowledge that
over the coming weeks and months that's
the joy of safari lives is that we
actually get to track the progress offer
these little ones as they grow up get a
bolder and start to explore the world
around them this has been truly
spectacular
so as a pretty attempts to manhandle or
hyena handle her cub that it brings us
to the end of this episode of the Safari
lives it's been an absolute pleasure
catching you up of the going ons of our
animals we'll see you next week and of
course tomorrow for the Regular Show hi
everyone
[Music]